Mạnh quình nói tôi rất nhiều khi làm bố, tôi đã đám phải ác xuất rồi.
Đôi khi quyền nghĩ nếu mà mình sống hơi sẽ còn nhá.
Mình cũng sẽ thuận là hơi hơi hơi hơi chút, một chút, và việc không không được nhiều, nhưng quyết quấn đi siện đó các người mà.
Nhưng mà, đôi khi tôi như những trong trình mà mình bố sẽ còn.
Thế tính như nghĩ lại, lại có lại thấy cái rây trương phật, và vì nếu mình đang sống hơi còn.
Thì mình đi phòng vẫn về mình đi kêu kim sau về là tôi lại mình lại về mình op con được rồi.
Là đôi khi là nghĩ là trải làm được rồi.
Con lại, một phút dây mà mình có thể ở mình đều.
Gần nhé là mình vẫn vẫn để tỏa sòng bên.
Mình cho biết con đến mình, mình cũng có ở mình bám sát yện ý những kêu chỉ hồi nó nhất.
Bà mình cũng một lượng một cái máy, và trong trình thì mình biết thì...
Ui tiên trong mình là đất đống, một vài tốt.
Để mình bị đống vài làm mình để mẹ không sử.
Thì quy tên rất là trời trời, nha, nó rất là mình cứ...
Gái trời, vì nó cứ kỳ phải được.
Gái tương rất là trọn đẹp và...
Vy ti sẽ phải...
Sẽ có một lý, sẽ phải...
Un ngắm, mẹ nhiều hơn.
Vynh thấy rất là quình.
Làm bố rất là nhanh và quình...
Mọi những lúc...
Bẹp ổ máy thuật.
Thì còn lại thì...
mình thật sự là được có thể một mình bàm trong...
Bộ đời.